yay I'm the second son of my family a
second coming of infamous Tomic Shay you
reviewed the good video game I really
love the infamous you do yeah guy Chris
waters gonna play the game and while we
have a little chitchat and actually just
woke up into the game where it's are we
the game just for con Seattle nowhere in
the game this is Tom's 100% virtuous
completion state so basically there's no
bad guys anywhere except for in this
little ring over here where I'm gonna go
attack them you have no power I'm using
smoke powers currently you there are a
number of powers you unlock throughout
the whole game Tom and I'm gonna I think
I'm gonna just use maybe two or three of
them awesome Tom I read your review nice
yeah it was great thank you very much i
read on the toilet it was wonderful for
him standing and i just want to ask you
this game some people have said you know
it's a little bit there's the open-world
game as we know is the modern open world
game and then the sort of used mobile
maybe division between what the sandbox
game was they like open war game at five
six years ago and then what we kind of
have come to expect in games like GTA in
assassin's creed so what was it about in
from the second son that like appeal to
you and regards stuff yeah I'm so like
Assassin's Creed in GTA are all about
like making the most realistic world
almost about yeah right and it's like
even historically accurate or it's
talking about more modern society and
there's real characters and all this
other you know serious yeah stuff so
this is a playground this is not this is
not a real city with real people this is
a playground for your amusement and it
feels just like the older sandbox games
used to be and I kind of loved that
because it just focuses on the action as
opposed to you know a narrative that may
or may not be
a lot of chaos do you find the the
play-by-play action in it from the
second son to be kind of more
entertaining then because I kind of I'm
with you on that because like when I
play GTA 5 I feel like I'm enjoying the
world more than I am enjoying the action
itself yeah like I don't know and GTA 5
is a great game yeah I don't think you
would hold that up against other
shooters yes or you'd hold it up against
other driving games so I don't think it
really i don't think it really compares
with the game that's like built from
that but i think you can actually
compare infamous to any action game on
the market like is it it is it is just
really fast and satisfying and diverse
compact and i absolutely loved playing
with all the powers inside and all the
enemies and coming up with tricks and
yes i think that's what their focus
wasn't that for this game really shine a
lot of the Paris and stuff they kind of
look like applicable maybe to you know
what we've seen in previous infamous
games what about the power is like made
you so excited about but action is so
the second power you get is neon neon
Chris is not using chris is actually
using concrete oh well me on hold on ah
so neon is basically back here all yeah
you gotta go looks like Simeon is like
do you remember the prototype game yes
surprise the prototype was pro that one
was kind of fun did you like prototype
just for the record we're missing
welcome did you enjoy a prototype
prototype one was clunky prototype 2 is
awesome yeah okay fair enough love
programs here so basically when you have
me on power in this its prototype three
okay you run straight up buildings like
a crazy person cuz like I livin this is
all like methodically climbing building
at oh this is ridiculous this is canon
super fast and you do that with in
combat because you need to move around
use your kind of a hill yep so it's just
like it's crazy over the top and it
looks gorgeous I don't know if you've
noticed it does look great in fact what
I will say is that when you were playing
last week we were all sort of huddled
around your computer yeah for a long or
your TV screen it looks better on like I
feel like increasingly it is getting
harder to display how good these games
look a
over video because it looks so much
better here than a dozen like when you
watch when they were even showing
trainers about yeah yeah because when
you're playing it and like the streets
it's raining in the streets there's like
puddles forming and you can see the
reflection of the neon lights through
the rain yeah and you're like oh this is
this is next-gen I just wait when you
finish this game where you disappointed
it was over that's always a good good
sign of a four-game why me when I finish
this game on a hundred percent
playthrough I did every single thing you
could I immediately started over on hard
extra difficult thing for an evil
playthrough and then when I finished
that I was disappointed oh yeah cuz I
just wanted more and more like it's just
this is my favorite open-world games
since prototype 2 I know there's just
not a ton of games like this like watch
dogs looks really cool it's coming out
but it's way different hmm so like it I
don't know what we're gonna get into the
game like this I was savoring every
second if you've got any questions for
Tom bed infamous add second son please
by all means put them in the chat and
I'll read them out here I want ask you
question as well you wrote a great
article about how you should play this
game in difficult mode yes explain the
sort of reason behind out like even
first time through it I would say so
because the first time through it it is
fun to like experiment with the powers
and just learn the story and all the
other stuff but like everyone's kind of
a pushover so by the halfway point I
didn't really fear combat anymore and I
was kind of making my own chill rise and
it's and I think I would have been more
engaged the first time if I really had
to like cause I didn't because the third
power you get in this game which I don't
have to mention mmm it's fantastic and
it's way different and I didn't use it
at all because I didn't we need to use
it yeah and then the second time through
it was harder I was like oh this is
really interesting i just had to put
some work into it so i would say the
first time through like if it really
pushes you to understand what the game
is doing from a combat perspective and
got a question here from reduce my god
is so cool gamespot what is the main
difference between this and previous
infamous games do you think there isn't
much of a there's a there's the combat
feels so the first infamous was really
methodical and it was all about like
lining up sniper shots and stuff like
that the second one was I thought to KI
for its own good because enemies was
like teleport all around you yeah I got
and then the screen would go black and
white and I couldn't tell what was going
and it was kind of frustrating for me
and this one is like right in between
where it's super chaotic but I still
knew exactly what was going on at all
times so it's like the best of both
worlds and plus the powers are way
different @chris you've been playing
infamous a little bit oh very not all
not a lot I don't may have noticed but I
love making you do this I don't want to
do all about my head talking a plan talk
and have a ribbon chairman yes be cool
you know if I were to play I look like a
fool so that's why I make this play and
so I've just been playing and I've only
got the smoke powers unlocks of course
they're still very early going but even
it's just like it has that I feel like
the thing that I've always loved about
the infamous series is that like
lightning smooth motion and just the way
that you you know can traverse around
the city the whole smoke power thing I'm
just like jetting into one of these like
vents in the side of the bill do it no I
gotta get as me honest I can only do
this thing which is wicked cool I can
only run up the side I can only write on
the side of a building I ever want Tom I
feel like I'm maybe not using like my
powers to their fullest advantage what's
a good movie but I mean my favorite
thing to do is when you hurt guys a
little bit you hit uh LOL one and that's
like you're like that thing but I
decided probably my favorite I that guy
i know that got built up a rock i give
concrete you've made of concert this is
like a really complex version of rock
paper scissors where it's like laser
sword beats Rock man but neon powerbeats
fire yeah basically is that true can
easily like dodge in and out of combat
and I think you know tom was sort of
saying like you know talking about how
what it's light it's different to play
on expert and so you know I think like
going toe-to-toe with a bunch of these
concrete dudes obviously is not like a
super awesome idea is Jocelyn like
dodging in and out there you go so
you've got that guy suspended in the air
and then if you shoot him oh looks like
I stole some concrete powers sorry oh
you did you don't I'm hurting anybody
right this game looks great I'm gonna
run around like you're the same ball
ball this thing that's so crazy about
this is in like what six years or a year
yeah six months per year we're gonna
look back and be like yeah they look
good yeah because like all of a sudden
you're gonna get you know
Naughty Dog's making and whatever sony
santa monica and all of a sudden this
game it's because it's an early ps4 game
yeah like we remember early ps3
specially open world games like when you
look back it like infamous one now and
even that looked like amazing yeah
welcome is one versus infamous 2 and
it's like yeah that's night and day and
so I can't wait until this looks like
junk d looking forward to my and do you
think this is fair to say that this is
the best first party game available on
the PlayStation 4 sine of the kills one
shadow fall well what about this resin
truss a good cigar doesn't can't doesn't
that got rad and it's an arcade e-type
game it doesn't so I can actually then
yes yes I mean this is Ayia hobo this is
my second favorite earth is my favorite
game on the platform I guess yeah cuz
I'm then tomb raider be number two oh
yeah um so yeah this is one of those
things if you bought a ps4 early like we
don't have to get this you have to get
this because it's super fun and it like
shows why you spent four hundred dollars
before you might not have had it super
easy to so that no the thing is crazy
about this is this game looks better
than Twitter even though yeah we can
open world its tomb raider looks
absolutely gorgeous but the confined the
world so i cannot wait for the future of
the system have it ahead as his hair
look do you ever take off his beanie you
can never take off these doctors note
rice effects there's no justify that
maybe that's what slow into your meter
down all right time it couldn't look
twice as good I'm getting super into
replaying games there because I had
ground zeroes should the fee oh yeah
explain this concept because I love that
so you if you're Fung is a good guy you
can't kill people like it's funny cat
it's a you can but so you got that like
an the upper left is like your super
move yes so each kill like builds up
part of that and then you have a super
movie on leash not of you if you kill
citizen or you kill someone you're
fighting here instead of subdue my lure
your dirt you lose all of your power and
it starts in a reset and like that force
you to play completely different yeah
because there's a good guy used to be
precise and shoot them in the feet and
is a bad guy I through Rockets like it I
was going to say the a word and then the
agent I get like an ass anarchist yeah I
got his whole hahaha again anarchical
Philly warrior on the game spot Collins
asked how long is the campaign
from the second son I think it took me
about 16 hours of for Istanbul really
about 16 to 20 the first time through I
understand it though the first time is
yeah and it's a little shorter so it's
shorter than the other infamous which
I've seen you I'm super into replaying
games at the moment cuz I'm playing a
bunch of gram zeros and all you can
really do with that game is replay it
and in from a second song obviously
there's no multiplayer component that it
snowing apart from playing it on hard
mode is there any other you know waiters
increased longevity of this game I've
actually been able to play through wine
for me and I'm better than Chris water
oh really yeah it's really the nursing I
don't like to I don't like when he talks
about it okay so one thing that's really
amazing that that sucker punch is done
is there some called paper trail okay
and it's I think it's 15 missions extra
missions they're both what you'd expect
to find in the game where it's like
Jason escort or whatever like that like
that kind of stuff and then like stuff
on the web is well and they're gonna
release that over the next few weeks oh
so is that like five extra hours of
content for zero dollars this is vero
euros and desert Ysidro again raising
veeramani free DLC yeah sucker punch
stay right there you can play the first
mission right now and then there's just
gonna be more mission I mean it was a
similar thing with what they did with
halo 4 right jack with the so what they
didn't pay before you talking about
Spartan Ops yes that that was sort of
you know like raid mission like a
multiplayer they they're on multiplayer
map type environments but they were
quick like raid missions further than
narrative yeah and so are these these
are these paper trail things are
narrative connection our narrative Lee
it is a side story that tells you more
about the DUP the government the dopes
rather to do it yeah i'm going to kill
these drug dealers in the park or but
this this is what I'm super me yeah yeah
so what do i do to do the super move on
what if you hit down on the d-pad all
right hey subdue you just murder him
with neon this heads it down to fetter I
want I want to hit a lot of drug dealers
oh here we go all stop dealing drugs in
the park it's a safe place for children
to be what you do is you like put all of
the people who are nearby into in
today's bubbles and fu master and the
whole screen does stuff they're gonna
kill the ps3 road bus bugs when they had
that drug box which is it's like up up
there yes this is their drug box well I
guess dog theaters always keep the drugs
in a drug I'm sure I'd in a good mother
man you've got a dolphin on it but like
I guess you want to go ride the dolphin
sure that makes sense you imagine how
much better San Francisco be if there
was so many with magically arresting
masses of drug dealers oh my god which I
also love how you trap them on the
ground with neon which is just like a
dumb gasps don't you pull it right oh
not even good guess McShay drop a
knowledge on the periodic table maybe
not even a no talking smack about the
game and it's got like ten and atomic
weight at hands I like oh good good job
you is accurate yeah did you what did
you do in Cook University I have an
Englishman is all right I did google
that before i wrote my reviews know the
atomic mass of the moon was don't you
pull your knee on paris from like the
bottom of people's car the guys who have
like tricked out their car you can you
can this is kind of why I like him from
a second son so the reason why this game
is inaccurate though is when I was in
Seattle like two weeks ago yeah first
time everybody drove a pretty perfectly
the games really have enough Priuses
every parking lot as at least you know
ten percent producing everything I want
to larious and the real Hades who uses
the let the number three as the e in
there just so in cases another debate
we're fine thank you I will there be
more web missions on TLC in the future
do you know post this paper trails I
mean a after paper yeah after that will
they will they hope so this is actually
sucker punch said they're gonna have a
new power oh wow so there's four powers
right now and they've strung and also
this game like details other powers
including paper which is a becoming this
is like Captain plans like there's
there's organic stuff with like plants
and then there's like
I don't know that glass sure paper they
talk about their experimenting with
these other ones they like concrete the
most all of these sound like street
names for drugs glass paper on the smoke
yeah are you open for sure is there a
subtitle so much happening in from the
second side although this takes place in
Seattle why you're on that out there why
is this guy a red icon is it just so i
can like come hang out with him and you
can do evil things to him can you
assault em please like please don't
please don't do music yeah [ __ ] off
that's an assault all and I killed him
why does it come up street musician
soulard because that is like a side
mission you can do if your insults all
the street musician get Seattle just if
you're a good guy you bust rugs if you
have got your assault speed which is
amazing and you know because the studio
sigra Funches from next door Seattle
totally calls Portland kirkwood
Bellingham its bellevue bellevue all
right you know they go to Seattle may
hate the street musicians their head in
the game you know what happened all
right Tomic say you've single-handedly
got me interested in from a second
assault duck all over again thank you
very much drugs in the sequel I want a
drum circle that I can disrupt that's
all Chris you can stop playing second
son there I'm beating up drugs Danny
it's for the children this is the worst
is the worst first in the world is the
worst senior drugs assaulter and street
musician the psalter Tommy Shay thank
you very much air five I don't want to
get in touch